[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and in
about a week exactly a week on next
monday google will be holding its event
where it pretty much every year
announces the next version of android
and a few devices to go with it this
year we're pretty much expected to see
the next nexus phone made by lg we're
expected to see a 32 gigabyte nexus 7
and maybe even a 3g version and a long
shot would be a 10 inch nexus 10 tablet
made by samsung there are also rumors of
multiple nexus devices potentially being
released by different carriers and
manufacturers htc motorola whoever
next year and in the future through a
certain program but you know it would be
interesting to see whether it happens
next week or next year
a nexus program a nexus program that
makes it possible for any manufacturer
to make a nexus certified device would
be pretty freaking cool just like you
see those stamps from intel on a lot of
intel certified computers with intel
chips inside there could also be a sort
of a nexus stamp of approval from google
but not just any phone can be a nexus it
would have to meet a certain set of
requirements to be able to be approved
and google would make these requirements
both hardware requirements and software
requirements hardware requirements would
just be basically future proofing the
devices making sure they're keeping up
with the nexus program so no hardware
buttons on the front they would just
have a larger screen and software only
buttons like the nexus program initiated
they would have maybe eight gigs of
internal storage minimum maybe a 1280 by
720 display minimum little basic stuff
like that and software requirements it
would have to run a pure stock version
of android provided by google which
means that all updates would be pushed
from google not from the current
manufacturer or the carrier and that is
the most difficult part of the program
because i'm sure while we'd all love to
see it happen it's not exactly the most
feasible the reason not every device by
the way has android 4.1 right now is
because the updates are not pushed by
google it's not stock android so you're
gonna see the updates being pushed out
by the people who are skinning android
so for example you have a motorola phone
with a motorola skin on top of android
motorola every time a new google android
update comes out has to make their
update work with the new version of
android before they push out their
update so while the new nexus might get
the update immediately your motorola
phone has to wait while motorola people
figure out how to make it work and then
the carrier will push it out basically
you're not getting your updates from
google if you don't have a nexus and
strangely enough even if you have a
verizon galaxy nexus you're still
waiting for verizon to push out the
update because they like to put some
verizon software on it so either way the
establishment of a nexus program that
allows you to pick a pure android device
from any manufacturer whatever hardware
specs you want would be pretty awesome
it's just a thought i had i figured it
would be neat to see what you guys think
of it and what what manufacturer would
you get your nexus from would you get a
motorola nexus or maybe a samsung nexus
or an htc one go ahead and leave that
down below the like button on this video
and i'll be sure to check out the best
of your answers below either way we'll
be finding out very soon exactly what
google has in store for us on monday
october 29th which is exactly a week
from right now we will get all this
stuff the playground is open as google
says so uh that's what we'll figure out
is uh exactly meaning by that what what
do they mean by the playground is open
we'll figure that out so thanks for
watching this video be sure to give a
thumbs up if you're excited just like i
am to see what google has to announce
this week and uh i'll talk to you guys
in the next video thanks for watching
peace
[Music]
you